[Music]
be
confident build your self-confidence
we're always told when we're growing up
confidence is attractive confidence
helps you get a job that you're applying
for
but where does confidence come from are
we born with it
absolutely not we can learn confidence
and sarah blakely the founder of spanx
she absolutely
learned how to build her confidence and
it's that self-confidence that helped
her
build a company without any debt without
any investors
and she became a billionaire
confidence is a powerful thing this
is a bit of optimism
[Music]
this is such a treat for me because i'm
such a fan of yours
i wanted to talk to you because one of
my this is one of my favorite things
about you
you have a kind of confidence that
few people i know have but you have this
sort of quiet calm about you this sort
of self self-deprecating sense of humor
and yet i know how much you believe in
yourself and believe in the things that
you do
and it's that sort of belief in your
direction
that i find just more magical
thank you the question i have is were
you always that way
or did it build over time i was
born with it to a certain degree and
then
there was a lot of work i did throughout
my life to cultivate it even more so
like like when i was 16.
you see how this is going to go right
yes i've been working on mindset since i
was 16. i can really say honestly i've
been a student of
um not what to think but how to think
and i had this revelation at the age of
16. you know i had two things happened
to me at that time in my life
one of my very close friends was run
over by a car and killed
in front of me and my dad
left home and my parents got separated
and ultimately divorced and when my dad
left home
he came into my bedroom and he handed me
a cassette tape series
called how to be a no limit person by
wayne dyer
and he said sweetie i wish i was your
age when i discovered this
instead of 40 and then he left and
i think most 16 year olds at clearwater
high on clearwater beach
probably would have chucked that middle
aged guy with the bushy mustache telling
me how to be a no limit person in the
bottom of my closet
but i was hurting so much that i was
open to it
and that's the hidden blessing for that
you know there's always a hidden gift in
in the darkest of times and my openness
to listening and
i just started crying sitting in my
bedroom as i put these cassette tapes in
because
i realized i'd spent 16 years plus in
school
being taught what to think but no one
had ever taught me how to think
and i had this epiphany of oh my god
wait i can control
how i think like i can actually work on
this and become a student of how to
think
so i really started getting as much as i
could
outside of school that was teaching me
how to not fear failure how to you know
take risks the law of attraction
visualizing my own success manifesting
what i wanted in my life
and then really i think more than
anything learning how to respond to what
comes at you in life like there's so
much stuff that's going to come at you
in life
and the way that you think about it is
either going to hold you back or propel
you forward
and learning that was really
enlightening for
myself so how did you learn to respond
to things that
don't go quote-unquote according to plan
i feel like the combination of how i
came into the world
i have had a deep center like a deep
sense of confidence about believing in
myself
if i feel like it feels right to me
and maybe it's a real connection to gut
and intuition
because there's a knowing inside of all
of us and we get distracted from the
knowing
but if i'm in connection with that
knowing it's almost like nothing can
rattle me
yeah one of the other things i know that
you have a mission
to empower women as well tell me about
how you found
yourself wanting to advance that mission
in the first place
right so i cannot pinpoint where that
comes from
i sometimes joke it must be a past life
passion
i didn't grow up in a family that was
like we need to support women
i think a lot of it had to do actually
with watching my mom
and my grandmother's limited options and
sort of absorbing that
i felt they were being held back whether
they even acknowledged it out loud or
said it it was just this feeling that i
had
and i just plainly see that the balance
between the masculine and the feminine
is so out of whack and so
i want to help it and i entered an arena
in business
that the masculine really ruled the
feminine is really
only been honored in this space
not that long ago when i started spanx
i had two guys come up to me and say you
invented something sarah congratulations
you know i hope you're ready business is
war
and i went home that night to my
apartment and i was so sad and i
remember sitting on the floor of my
apartment and saying
why is it war like why does it have to
be work
and i vowed to myself that night i was
like i'm going to do it differently i
don't want to go to war
and i just honored very feminine
principles
in how i conducted myself and grew my
business
and in the back of my mind i was
thinking maybe i'll end up successful
and if i do wouldn't that be
cool because then i can show there's
another way yeah what are some examples
of those principles
i mean using vulnerability i've been
very guided by my intuition
i'm in a business group with guys and i
would say things like well i'm gonna
talk to the universe i'm gonna consult
with the universe
and they like literally thought i was
insane and then as my business continued
to grow
around year four or five i found out
later i'm still in the business group
with them 20 years later they're like my
brothers but
they all told me they were placing bets
how long i would last in business
four or five years into its time and
they all individually were pulling me
aside
and they were like so how do you talk to
the universe
tell me what you mean but so
vulnerability i'll give you an example
i started spanx i make butts look better
starting with my own
i took a picture of my own butt with
cellulite
and a panty line in my pants and then
put my product on and showed it side by
side and laminated it at kinko's and
stood in neiman marcus right like this
store with the most impeccably dressed
women and i'm showing this image of
myself
and over and over again i had people say
you know
if you're the founder and the owner and
you probably should use someone else's
butt like why are you using you know
they couldn't wrap their head around the
fact that
i wasn't trying to say you need me
i'm perfect i have a product for you i
was kind of like
we're in this together this is what this
does for me
and that was a real shift at the time as
a consumer i always felt like
companies were talking at me and not to
me
and i feel like there was a real fear
among companies
that if we put our guard down like if we
acted
real human or kind of at the level of
our customer
they might not believe we're credible
like that we're not the expert
and that they don't need our products so
i just stripped that all away and then i
had such a deep connection with
consumers as a result simon
spanx didn't advertise for 16 years
i became a global household name without
ever advertising
and i truly believe it's because there
was this approach to the consumer that
the women were feeling
something so different and sharing it
with all their friends and that's
the ad campaign but this taps into this
confidence that i
adore i think there's an irony here
which is people think confidence
is being strong well that's because
there was no place
in the workplace for vulnerability
vulnerability was seen as a weakness to
me vulnerability
takes great strength and it's the
deepest way to connect with another
human being
you know like i love deep connecting
whether it's a customer
or a friend and i find that happens the
most when i'm
authentically just who i am right
how old were you when you met jesse your
husband i was
35 i got married at 37.
did you want to get married prior i
wanted to get married
and had you had a couple of full starts
were you ever engaged prior to jesse
yes i was engaged before jesse i had
many many relationships that weren't
right
i really wanted to be married i really
wanted children
i had a lot of this conflict inside of
my body in my 20s because
i would meet men they would be really
nice
they would want to get married and i
would feel like
if i married them i might not
figure out my full potential so if you
married them you wouldn't
back up them i so i had
you know all these opportunities to
marry men
who were very interested in taking care
of me or just
you know very successful whatever and i
would have this inner conflict that was
so
intense that would say but if you do
that you might become content
and you might not ever learn
your full potential of what you're
capable of and what you could do
and it was like a knowing inside of
myself that i
almost knew that that would happen to me
i just was like i need to find my way
first
kind of i was very determined to
be financially independent my mom and
dad got divorced my mom had been a
stay-at-home mom
all her life and then i'm sitting at
home with her
and i'm a freshman in high school
when it all makes sense to you i said
well mom you know
what's your savings you know i don't
have any savings
do you have a 401k do you have a pension
no i've been a stay-at-home mother
i was like okay and it was a really
intense time for me as a
15 and 16 year old girl to kind of
absorb
all of that so you resisted marriage for
a long time so what was it
i resisted it but i wanted it i could
spend time on a therapy couch about that
but
it's all worked out i found my husband
in vegas at a poker tournament naturally
[Laughter]
go on i don't think i've ever heard the
story of how you and jesse met
i met jesse in vegas at a poker
tournament and neither one of us play
poker
and wait so you're both in the poker
tournament yes
that's even better
[Laughter]
and then i just kind of knew i was like
oh boy
i was like this guy's in my movie i
never
could see any of the guys i was with
prior to jesse in my movie
and as soon as i met jesse you know he
lived in new york i lived in atlanta
we were in vegas the whole thing was you
know he was an entrepreneur i had
started spanx
but i just i just saw him in my movie
i absolutely love that terminology you
know what it is it's a very clever
device
to trust your gut because i've dated
people and i've
you know i've liked them and and i
thought could i
could i end up with this person you know
could i end up with her and i
and i play this game like well she has
these qualities but these qualities
but if i simply say can i see her in my
movie the answer is no
amazing human being right but not in my
movie
right and it allows someone to not have
to
explain why it doesn't feel right but
rather accept
that it doesn't feel right exactly it's
a clever device
yeah you talked earlier about the law of
attraction
how do you know that it exists how have
you been able to follow the law of
attraction
and listen to the universe i have been
calling on the universe to help me
it's visualizing i will see something
before it happens and i will then
fill in the blanks in college i
visualized myself on the oprah show i
with 100
certainty saw myself sitting on stage
with oprah
and we were talking and i was certain of
it
and the next you know 10 to 12 years i
called filling in the blanks
i had no idea what i was going to be on
oprah and i
actually was so excited i remember in my
20s being like
i can't wait to find out what i'm
talking to her about
and i mean i ended up at disney world
because i failed the
l stat to be a lawyer i was too short to
be goofy i'm
the height of chippendale i'm at the
height of a chipmunk
then you know then i sell fax machines
door-to-door for
seven years i mean i get kicked out of
every office building all day long
every day in clearwater florida i'm
living with my mom like i'm dating
the wrong guy after the wrong guy and if
you had pulled me off the side of the
road in my honda at any given moment in
that time
i would have been like with 100
certainty i'm on oprah it's going to
happen
and then all of these things started
happening and
and i was on oprah if anyone whispered
in my ear
as a 20 year old at the you know in
florida
that you're going to be talking to her
about a new product you create
as an undergarment you know it's like i
would have thought they were insane you
know
i'd never taken a business class i've
never worked in fashion or retail
but that was a 100 visualization
i love this because a lot of people look
a lot of people have told themselves
they're going to be on oprah
right a lot of people have said
themselves and a lot of people have
believed it
but after the second year or third year
of selling fax machines
they start to doubt the vision the
confidence starts to go
sideways because the timing isn't as
they expected
and you sold tax machines for seven
years
and that's a long time i mean the
average person at that company lasted
like six months
it was so intense i mean you you got
kicked out of buildings all day long i
mean i got escorted out of buildings
because i had to do a hundred percent
cold calling
so every morning i would get in my car
and walk into businesses
unannounced and try to sell them a fax
machine clearly you figured out how to
sell somebody a fax machine if you
lasted seven years doing it
it was brutal though you know what did
you learn from that that has benefited
you now
oh my god what didn't i learn it's like
one of the best
things you could ever do to prepare for
life i learned how to
get my foot in the door you're really
only given about 30 seconds to a minute
and i figured out how to approach
someone in those first 30 seconds to a
minute to get a possible chance
it was true sales and i think sales is a
really important part of life i think
no matter what you do in life there's
sales right
you're selling yourself in a job
interview you're selling
your kids to eat the broccoli at night
you know
and i got really good at understanding
customers and how to communicate and
listen to them and
and deliver and not taking rejection
personally
right oh my god i mean i cried a lot i
mean i would get in my car
after being like yelled at you know a
lot of receptionists used to rip my
business card
up in my face as i handed it to them and
i just have to like
take a deep breath and go well thank you
very much you know if anything
comes up call me and then i get in my
car and i'd cry
but i was listening all the time
to wayne dyer tony robbins
zig zigler brian tracy like you couldn't
have been
in my car in the 90s without
you know putting your feet on like 50
different cassette tapes that were
people talking about you know how to
think and goal setting
and and i don't know i just really
i just was really drawn to all of that i
actually took it to my principal at
clearwater high
and said can we please teach this i said
this is changing my life
and he kind of laughed at me and was
like no i said can we just maybe get rid
of homec
like like an elective you know like do
we really need homec anymore could we
make it
mindset and could we just play these
cassette tapes
because i couldn't get over what the
impact it had on me
and all of my friends you know simon and
i went to clearwater high like i went to
a public high school
they were always fighting over who had
to be in my car after a party because
they're like
she's gonna make you listen to that [ __ ]
and it was
always playing and then you know fast
forward like you know
10 or 15 years and i'm on the cover of
forbes and i get all these texts from my
friends at clearwater high and all they
write was damn should've listened to
that [ __ ]
that's so funny do you teach all that
stuff to your your the folks who work
with you
yes every new hire gets a how to be a no
limit person
that tape series that's fantastic and do
you still cry
yeah i still cry i still doubt myself
i have days where i'm like oh my god i
don't know what i'm doing
yeah so i have had to push myself
really really hard to do what i've done
i've been terrified i've been scared i
mean
at every turn i was scared but i always
say
when you make what you're doing about
something other than yourself
if your why is bigger than you and for
me
my why is about
women and the feminine being raised
and so i found courage i never knew i
had
and that propelled me to do things that
didn't feel as natural for me especially
as
a woman but literally it sounds dramatic
but when i was like sitting in my rental
car in dallas and
deep breathing to go into the neiman
marcus headquarters to make my first
spanx call
i just remember i was always like you're
doing this on behalf of women
you're walking through that door for
your mom and your grandmothers who
didn't have this choice
and this opportunity you're walking
through that door for all the women
around the world who still don't have
this opportunity
so get your ass out of the car and walk
through the door
and like shaking in my boots you know
this is significant
because ultimately human beings are
animals of service you know we're social
animals
and to do something in the service of
others we find courage
where to do it for yourself it's much
more difficult i like to joke that i'm
very happy to let myself down
[Laughter]
but i don't like letting other people
down right but i also like how you
thought about your mother and your
grandmother you know the marine corps
talks about this
they talk about those who came before us
right that we cannot let the sacrifices
of those
who came before us go in vain completely
because it's too difficult to talk about
the abstract future
you know do it for our children nobody
makes the right decisions for their
children
that's interesting but rather we're
actually much more beholden to the past
because the past is tangible and so you
kept invoking your mother and your
grandmother you cannot let
their sacrifices and the things they
gave up for you
go in vain you had to work harder so
that their sacrifice was worth it
yes how do we teach girls
to have your confidence you know i think
that for one the more female examples
out there
that are really authentically vulnerable
and not perfect
and living a life that they might aspire
to
you know i want young girls to see
themselves in me like when i was on the
cover of forbes they're like we want you
in a suit we want you with your arms
crossed i'm like
why does ultimate success have to look
so serious yeah
and so not enjoyable like i really like
representing
my house is the mess i'm trying to
figure it out and i put the cookies on
the wax paper by accident instead of the
parchment paper and
like all of this stuff but then i feel
like i have a chance for younger girls
to see themself in me
and if they see themself in me and i'm
not putting on a real
front then i feel like they might tap
into something and say
why not me the irony is is that we need
men to act more like you also
you're empowering women but i think men
have this tremendous pressure to put on
the air as you know this is war
act tough and i think one of the things
that your example provides is no
no just have fun be yourself let the
guard down
all that artifice let it go and by the
way this is
beneficial to a human being i feel it's
happening
yeah don't you feel it yeah i feel a
shift for sure
happening for men i think men are
getting more and more comfortable and
there's more
permission because men have feminine and
masculine
energy i have both in me i honor both
yeah
i could not have done spanx without the
masculine energy inside of me
i just didn't want to do it by saying i
will play by these rules and completely
annihilate and squash the feminine
yeah you know there are these
traditional male characteristics as you
talked about like aggression
decisiveness you know
and there's these traditional female
characteristics like
patience and empathy and it's not so
much that we need more
female leaders it's that we need more
leaders to act like
females and women just happen to be
better at that
i just think it's about balance it's
balance it's exactly right i think our
society is over
indexed on masculine energy to our
detriment
rugged individualism and aggression and
all this stuff we just over-indexed
it's not that it's unnecessary it's that
the balance is too far off we need to
recalibrate our society to find a
rebalance of energy
completely and everything you embody is
not feminine it's balance
right and you know as a woman entering
the workforce the women that came before
me
they had to act like men to have even a
remote chance
to be accepted in that arena so when you
say
in the marines or in the military you
honor the people that come before you
i have so much gratitude for those women
because those women
played in the arena they all had to
look and dress and act like men you know
cut their hair short and wear a pantsuit
right but they paved the way for me to
be where i am
and i was determined to wear a dress
when i wanted to and to paint my nails
i've done my journey very feminine and
honoring that
i know it's because people paid their
dues before me
and when i think about timing simon
i mean my mother is 22 years older than
me
so you think about timing human beings
have been on the planet
you know depending on who you ask and
what you believe thousands of years or
millions of years
either way it's been a while and
i made the cut by 22 years my mom
was expected to be a homemaker her
options were really really
really limited i mean the fact that 22
years later i could
start my own business and have this
opportunity
you know i have a board game hanging at
spanx that says the exciting
game of career women and it was
mattel i think that came out with the
board game in
the mid to late 60s right when my mom
was getting married and everything and
there were five options
it was teacher nurse ballerina
socialite and flight attendant
social light was a career option like oh
no
those were the options so it's hanging
here at spanx
because we have lots and lots of women
that work here and there a lot of them
are in their 20s and so
just having them see that board game
they're kind of like what is that
like that wasn't that long ago true
sarah thank you so much for taking the
time
you're welcome sarah such a joy such a
joy such a joy
wishing you only the best and we'll talk
real soon
all right thanks for having me bye
if you enjoyed this podcast and you'd
like to hear more please subscribe
wherever you like to listen to podcasts
until then take care of yourself take
care of each other
you